STEVE: PRESIDE BIDEN YESTERD
WITH A WNING TO UNVACCINATE
AMERANS, WINTER ISOMING AND
IT GOING TO BE BAD.
>> FOR UNVACNATE WE ARE
LOOKING AT A WINTER OF SERE
ILS
, THEIR FAMILIE
AND THE HOSPITALSHAT WILLOON
OVERWHELMED,UT THERE'S GOO
NE.
YOU'RE VACCINATEDND YHAVE YOUOE
PROTECD FROM SEVERE ILLNESS
AND DTH, PERD.
AINSLE THIS  THE PRESIDENT
RESPONSEO T PANDEMIC GETSITS WO.
N FOXUSESS POLL SHOWS
ARLY HALFFOU, HF OFAMA, DISAPPRS
PERFORNCEN COVID NOW
IAN: EREOEACT SOUTH
DAKOTA GOVERNOR KRTI NM.
IT'S GNG TO BE A DK
WINTERT LOOKS LIK GOVERR.
WHO YOU PLANNOING TOYOUR PEOE?
WE PLAN ON DOING BINESAS
USUAL AND CELEBRANG
CHRIMAS.
I TNK THE PSIDE'S OUTLOOK
IS FOCG ON THE NEGATES.
IS COUNTRY NEEDS HOPE.
THEY NEEDO REMEMBER THE
PROME OF CISTM, A
THE LO THEY HAVE FOR TIRFAMILIEY
THE SEASON.
BRIAN:  B THE NUMBERS ARE RISIN.
E YOU?
WE'RE ALWAYS CONCERNED.
WE'RDOINGHE HARD WORKFTAKING CEG
THEM USE PERNAL RPONSIBILITY
TOAKE THE BEST
DESIONS FOR THEELVES AND
THEIR FAMILS, AND THEN
CUSING ONOW WE CANET
THROUGH CHALLENGI TIMES
TOGETHER.
SOH DAKOTA HASEEN AN AMPLE
TO THE COURY OFOWOU DOTHAT WITHD
PROTECNG FREEDOMS A IOULD
COURE THE PRESIDE TO
CONSIDER TAKING SOMOF T
ACTION THA WE HAVE.
STEVE:OR INSTANCE WHAT?
BEUSE TORIAN'S PNT THE
NUMBS ARE RISING, THE
NUMBER OF HOSPITAZATIONS
IN LAST TWO WEEKSP 20%.
THEYRE EXPTING, GOVNOR, IN
ABOUT TEE WKS, THE DEATH
TOLL, BECAU OF COV, LARGE,
DELTA, WILL B 15,000 PER WEEK
HERE IN THE UNITED STATE
SOHAT CMON SENSE THISS
SOUTH DAKOT DOING THA THE
PRESIDENT SHOUL DO?
>> WE WILLONTINUE TO DO IT.
WE'VEONE THROUGHOUT T
PANDEMICND THAS TO
INFORMEOPLE, GIVE THEM DATFOCUSR
HAND LIK WE DIDHROUGHOUT THE
ANDEMIC, TOAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE NOT FEELING WELL, THEY
OULD STAOME, PROTECT THEVULNABLD
CHOOSE TOET A VACCINEF THEYWOUL.
IF THEY DON'T, TN GO INTO THIS
KNOWING TT THEY SULD
FOS O ERCISING, TING
EIR VITAMS, AND BEING VERY
ALTHY PEOPLE.
AINSLE GOVERR, I KNOW THAT
YOU WANT TO INTRODUCE THEIRLS
SPORTS BL.
TELL THE FOLKS A HOME WHAT THIS
S ANDHY.
>> WELL, WE DID FILE THAT BILL
THIS WEEK.
WEO INTO SESSION JANUARY,
BUT THIS BILLOULD ESSENTIAL
TAKE THE EXECUVE ORDS THAT I
T IN PLACE LT YEAR ACODIFYHEM ID
WHAT THE DO IS PROTECT FAIRNESS
IN WEN'SPORTS,OR GIRLS.
MAKEURE THAT THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE SUCCESSL
SO WE ONLY HE GLS PLAYING IN
RLS SPORT
IT WOULD ARESS IT  THE K2
LEVEBUTO AT THE CLEGIATE
LEVEL HERE IN OUR STE.
STEVT'S CPLICATED BECAUSE
THEREREOW TRANS-ALETES
MPETING IN SRTS IN GENDER,
HEATEGORIESOR GDERS
THAT THE WERE N BORN AS
OPLE WHO WERE BORN AS BOYS ARE
NOW TRANS AND NOWOMPETING WITHW.
>> HEREREERYHYSICAL
DIERENCES BETWE MALES AND
FEMAS, AND THAT ISNE OF THEISESG
ABOUT AS THBIOLOGICAL
DIFFERENCES AND MING SURE THATWS
SO THAT GLS HE A LEVELPLING FIE.
THEY HAVE T OPPORTUNITY T BE
CCESUL, AND THAT' SOMETHI
THATAS FOUGHT F MAN YEA
AG THAT WE, HEREN SOUTH
DAKOTA, WILROTECT THAT RIGHT
FOR THOSE GIRL
BOYS SHOD PY IN BOYS SPORTAND GS
SPORTS
BRIA  JUST LEAH THOMASS T
IMMER AT THE UNIVEITY OF
PENNSYLVANIAWITCD SEXES AND
NOW A WOMAN,OMPETING AND
BLOWING OUT T COMPETITION,ND
TUS OUT A L OF THE TEAMMATES
, A LOTF THE
PARES OF THEEAMMATES OF
R O TEAATES ARE UPSETABOUT THIS.
THEY HAD THEIRWNOA AND
THEY RAC THEY WANTE TO
WIN, AND HE IS A QUOTE FROM A
FEMALEWIM SWIMMER SPEAKG OUT
AINST THOMAS.
IT'SARD WORKING YOU WHOLE
LIFE AT SPORT GOING TO TIG
COMPETION SING SOMNE MOREPHYSICU
HOWEVE IT'SORE DISCOURING
TO HE THEM RIGHT NEX TO YOU
OWING YOU WON EVER BEN
SAM PHYSICAL LEV AS THEM.
SO THAT I EXACTLYHAT THIS IS
ABT ISN'T IT?
I IS AND I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE ACROSS THE COURY ARE
TRNG TO TAKE THIISSUND
MA IT INTERSONAL BELIEFS O
T SEND A MESSA ON A
DIFFERT ISE WHEN REAY,
AT THIS COMESOWN TO, ISFAIRNESS.
FAIRSS FOR GIRLS, GIVING THEMAET
EN THEY COMPETE IN THESE
ORTS THEY CAN BEUCCESSFUL
AND TY HAVE THE OORTUNITY TO
GO ON, GO TO COLGE, GETSCHOLARSA
PROFESSIONAL, ANDAKEURE THAT
EY'R COMPETING AINST
SOMEE WHOSE GIV T SAM
GI AND THEAME LEVEL OFPHYSICALBE
WE.
STEVE:OVERR, BEFORE YOU GO,
WE'L HAVE YOU WEIGH IN ONOME
POLICS, OVER THE LAST WK OR
SO, THERE BEEN SOME
SPECULATIONBOUT WHETHER OR
NOT JOE BIDENLDUN FOR
RE-ELECTION AND INACT THE
NEW YORK TES ONHE OP-ED
PA SAID JOE, D'T RUN BUT
TELL PEOE NOW.
WH DO YOU THINK IS GOINGO
HAPPEN ON THEEMOCRAT SE?>> I TD
THE VICE PRESIDENTAVE
DIUSSE THIS ISSUE.
I THI THEY DISREE ONHE
BESTATH FORRD FOR THEIR
PAY.
THEY'V GOT A LOT O DIVISION
G ON AND IT'LL BEINTERESTG TO WY
DO IN T FUTURE.
WHAT I KNO IS THE PICIES OF
PUBLICANS ARE WORKING
PEOPLERE SUCCESSFUL,NDNITIES,OU,
REBLANS AND CONSERVIVES
ARE HPIER BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE
THAT WT WE BELIEVE TRU DOE
OTEC WHAT MES AMERICA SO
IA
BRN:  SO Y BELIEVEHERE'S
DIVISION BETEN J BIDEN AND
KAMA HARRIS?>> I DO.YOU CAN S .
THEY ARET COMMUCATING.
EY AN'T GETTING ANG AND I
THINK TRE'S A LOT OF DIVISIO
HE WHITE HOUSE RIG NOW
TWEEN THOSE T.
AINSLEY: HE SAYS HS RUNNING
AGAI AND SHE SAID WE HAVEN'TDIS.
ES THAT MEAN HE'S PSIBLY
OKING FOR ANOTHER CANDIDATE TO
BE HIS VP?
>> ELL LOOK AT T DOCRATIC
PAY.
THEIR LEADERSH OIOUSLY HAS
POOR ABILITY TO DECIDE WHENOSTEE
YER, JOE BEN, TY'VE
GOT YOUNG LDERS THAT AREFRUSTRAT
VERY DIFFERE AGENDA F THI
COUNTRY.
'S IERESTING TO WCH WHAT'
ING ON IN THE DEMOCRATI PARTY
BECAUSE I DON'T BIEVE IT
FLEC AMERICA RIGHT NOWND
THE AMERICANEOPLE IS WAKING UP
TO IT.THAT'S WHY PARTS ARE SHOW,
CITY CNCILS, THEY'RE TAKINEIR CK
THAT MEANS THAT IT'S GOING T BE
AREAT MID-TMS FOREPUBCAS.
BRIAN:  THEY FEE OPTISTI
ABOUT THE HOU AND WE'LL SEEAT'SN
THE NATE.
AINSLEY: REMEMBER IN LOUDOUN
COUNTY THAT PENT PEL, LIKE
12F TM THEYLL SAID W
DI'T EVEN KNOW WHO OUR SCHOOL
E
ALL SPEAKUT AT THE MEETING
STEVE: TO YOUR PNT A LOT OF
FRUSTRION.
GOVERNOR THANK YOU VY MH FOR
JOINING US TODAY.
AINSY: MERRY CHRISTMAS
GOVERNOR.
MERRY CHRISAS YOU GUYS
HAVE A WONRF